phó mừng đam cờ, năm tên yên ở vẻ ăn bị tạm dưới hình sự.
Phó khoảng 12, 7,5 m左右 nè mì hai tháng mời, thông qua mậu giả hợp phê bước,
công gân tị sả hợp mai phát hiện tại nhà mỗi định lớn,
xin nămu hình chỉ trăm bệ vý móc, chủ tệ phần quình xuân,
tị sả hợp mai đã đất phó nổ trong cả trịng tổ chức đam cờ,
kê sọ ký phát hiện vụ việc, danh vì đánh đình trống cờ lực lượng tập trung đều trà,
sất mình làm sống.
Phó đó, sất định khó năm lưỡi tự nhiên quan bầu hộng định đình trường,
xin nămu hình chỉ trăm chiếm mê tư vốn mình thoại xin nămu hình chỉ trăm tảm mấy chính,
vốn hộ hộn vình xin nămu hình chỉ trăm tảm mấy tảm,
lưu vấn đình xin năm hành hình công trăm liền sảo,
cùng chú tại phần quình xuân, thị sát hợp mai,
và vỗ phần hộng xin nămu hình chỉ trăm tảm mấy sảo,
chủ tại sát hợp xuân, quyền ăn xuân,
cơ quan khảnh sát đều trà công hàn thị sát,
là sao cất định tạm giữ hình sự năm nữa tượng ngờ trên
về hành vi gây giấu chật tự cộng lòng.
Đông thời đang cùng của hộ sơ,
tay liệu được kính hành khởi tổ vụ an,
khởi tổ cất bí cân,
nhăm ra đe phòng người chung,
hết là hạn chỉ tối ra vực sự dụng phảo chai khác,
phép chút trong bởi sâu tất miền đàn hành in công trăm hành liền.